voilà dix ans que les chinois se sont
massivement implanté en afrique
il serait 750 milles sur tout le
continent nous en avons croisé beaucoup
dans notre périple en chine afrique mais
il nous restait un mystère à élucider
rarement nous les avons vu boire une
bière avec leurs collègues africains
après le travail et jamais nous n'avons
trouvé de couples mixtes les patrons
chinois nous ont dit que s'ils
surprenait l'un de leurs ouvriers avec
une africaine
il serait renvoyé en chine de toute
façon affirmé t-il les cultures
africaines et chinoises ne sont pas
faites pour s'accorder au sein d'un
couple vraiment un peu partout nous
avons cherché des enfants métis nombreux
selon la rumeur africaine invisible en
réalité jusqu'au jour où nous avons
frappé à la porte de bêta dans la petite
ville de chambishi en zambie où des
chinois exploite la mine de cuivre
locale le garçonnet qui viennent
d'ouvrir à la peau claire et les yeux
il appelle sa mère bêta à 24 ans et deux
enfants pas comme les autres dawanda et
booba sont nés de père chinois bêta
hésite longtemps puis nous raconte
l'histoire de sa vie elle est la cadette
d'une famille de mineurs ses deux soeurs
font leurs droits elle aussi doit partir
faire ses études
quand sa vie bascule à 17 ans elle est
élue la plus belle fille du village
mitshubishi une célébrité locale ce
moment de gloire a marqué son destin son
insu ce soir là un chinois se lève dans
la salle pour la féliciter
il lui sort le grand jeu numéro de kung
fu compris
il est un excellent tommy s'efface comme
la prochaine année médiatique et meego
friedrich et a dit oui après tout sa
copine judith sort elle aussi avec un
chinois au centre de loisirs bêta ne
manque pas une soirée monsieur wang lui
offrent de l'argent et même un téléphone
portable
[Musique]
voilà bêta stigmatiser monsieur langue
disparaît d'un coup sans doute en chine
quelques mois plus tard bêta accouche
d'une petite métisse interloqués les
parents de bêta finissent par déclaré
que cet enfant est un don de dieu
tawanda don de dieu en bemba sera son
nom bêta retrouve une certaine
insouciance au gré des fêtes de
chambishi ses amis et pousse des gars du
village bêta en reste aux amants zambien
de passage qui grimacent lorsqu'il
découvre que sa fille à la peau cuivrée
au marché les rumeurs vont bon train
d'autant qu'un autre chinois monsieur
chang a été aperçu à plusieurs reprises
lorsqu'ils entraient ou sortaient de
chez elle à l'automne 2004 elle lui
annonce qu'elle est enceinte lendemain
monsieur de chang est renvoyé en chine
en avril bêta à couche de boue pas dont
les traits asiatiques sont encore plus
marqués cette fois ses parents la jette
à la rue
il faut dire qu'entre temps à chambishi
la tension entre chinois et zambien a
atteint son paroxysme après l'explosion
de la mine
les chinois ne sont pas pressés de
dédommager les familles des victimes
dans ce climat hostile les enfants de
bêta 2 viennent de petits métiers sont
eux désespéré bêta implore l'aide du
chef de camp chinois
il lui claque la porte au nez le père de
booba ne peut pas être chinois dit-il
car ses employés reçoivent tous un
traitement stérilisant
ce culte même des cas d'espèce
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous pas trois ans et ne
passe jamais la porte du jardin
sa mère n'a pas les moyens de le
scolariser elle n'en a d'ailleurs pas
très envie comme d'autres petits
sino-africain boubaya ou honda sont
aujourd'hui tenus à l'écart par les deux
communautés
mais lorsque les relations entre la
chine et l'afrique auront mûri le jour
viendra peut être où ses enfants métis
seront considérés comme les pionniers
d'une nouvelle afrique